red cross told us this morning that
everyone inside the convention center
now has a cot and people can also now
take showers you remember that yesterday
we spoke to a woman who complained about
the conditions inside
she was just letting us know she wasn't
really complaining just kind of letting
us know it's tough inside there we went
back later in the day to see the
situation for ourselves
houston wasn't prepared
the government wasn't prepared the mayor
wasn't prepared
michelle lavonne's frustration has only
grown since a dump truck brought her
family to the george r brown convention
center what's their shoe sign we found
stacks of second hand shoes and
mountains of donated clothing but what
about beds this is just one of five
rooms
filled with cots like this all were
taken by the time lavon arrived she
showed us her accommodations the faded
air mattress
cardboard boxes how many adults and how
many kids are supposed to sleep all in
here five adults three kids
that's pretty tight
yeah
welcome to my new home volunteers gave
sticker books to her children while the
family hangs in limbo waiting to find
out what happens next what has your
family been doing all day yes
nothing for them to do
what are the bathrooms like
horrible charlie you're running this
shelter here correct charles maltby is
with the american red cross which as a
partner of fema is responsible for
running shelters like this
houston is a big city fourth largest in
america as you know the plan was only to
fit 5 000 people
how could that be
that is a good question
that's something that
what we really look to do is have
smaller shelters available we try and
house folks as close to their
homes as possible
and this really was more of a evacuation
site the assumptions that were in place
even a week ago when we were standing
this up just have been completely
overwhelmed they're saying no one
expected the storm to be this bad
they expected it they knew
we have weather men and women for a
reason
they knew this was going to happen
they knew this
now to be clear forecasters did predict
rainfall of up to two and a half feet in
some spots but not the historic amounts
that we have seen so far
red cross organizers say they hope even
more supplies will arrive at the shelter
today i was told yesterday there's
something like 20 trucks from all across
the country that are trying to make it
here to houston